una vez más una carrera contra el tiempo
desmoralizante no nos metimos en esta
profesión solo para tratar kobe francia
se puso al día con la variante de
omicron este miércoles el número de
casos positivos llegó a más de 200.000
una cifra nunca antes alcanzada desde el
inicio de la pandemia del cob y 19 jul
esta pauta le indica que seguirá
subiendo y que podríamos llegar según
las proyecciones a más de 250 mil casos
diarios a principios de enero lo que es
desproporcionado con respecto a lo que
hemos experimentado desde el comienzo de
la pandemia el punto por el momento el
número de pacientes hospitalizados no ha
aumentado drásticamente
casi 3500 personas están en cuidados
intensivos en francia en comparación con
los más de 7000 en el pico de la primera
ola en el año 2020
la cuestión es el estado físico y
psicológico del personal de enfermería
llevamos dos años con esta enfermedad
dos años de olas dos años de trabajo
extra para poder gestionar las olas por
desgracia ahora el personal está cansado
este mes y una frase se está
convirtiendo en el país más afectado de
europa por coronavirus sin cierres ni
toques te queda este miércoles el
parlamento francés analiza el proyecto
de ley con miras a transformar el pase
sanitario en un pase de vacunación